Hi, my name is Jeremy Gilley.
I'm a filmmaker.
In 1998, I was sick and hurt about what was going on in the world.
The starvation, the destruction, the killing of innocent people.
I was trying to make sense of a war that I was growing up in and finding it difficult.
And so, I wanted to see if I can make a film about peace.
But I realized there was no day of peace.
There was nothing that united the world above politics and above religion.
We have an Earth Day, we have a Valentine's Day.
We should surely have a Peace Day.
So, I decided to try and establish the first ever Peace Day with a fixed calendar day.
A day of ceasefire, a day of nonviolence,...
...a day of intercultural cooperation on a scale that we've never known before.
So, I set out in 1999...
...and I traveled the world meeting people like the Dalai Lama, Kofi Annan,...
....Shimon Peres, Dr. Oscar Arias, Mary Robinson;...
...going into Burundi, Somalia, Gaza, West Bank, India, Sri Lanka, Central America;...
...all over the world.
What I learned is, from speaking to humanitarians...
...who are dealing with saving people's lives on a daily basis,...
...is that if we had a day of ceasefire and nonviolence,...
...we can immunize children, move aid, lives could be saved, children could be inspired.
It was a day that had immense benefit.